こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
はーいどうも皆さんこんにちはつる兄ーーーです！！
やっちゃいましたねやっちゃいましたｗ
あのフリスビーこうなんか(必死
こうやって投げる奴があるんですけども〜
それの世界記録を調べてみました！
人間が世界一遠くに投げられる物体
エアロビーって言うフリスビーがあるんですけども
４００m、４００メートル…
でその世界一遠くに飛ぶために使われた
フリスビーが今、買ってあります。
ちょ持ってくるわ！
これが世界一飛ぶフリスビー！
もう買いました！
(なかなか開かないお…)
あ！こういう感じね！！！
エアロビーって書いてあります、
エアロビープロ400って書いてあるやつが
400ｍ飛ぶから400って書いてあるのかな？
これ！
《人間の力だけで最も遠くへ飛ぶリング！》
なんだって！
まぁまぁまぁまぁまぁ
ちょっとあの、、
この腕毛が気になるところなんですけども、
すごいでも本当にめっちゃ飛ぶらしいんですよ、実際
とりあえずちょっと遊んでみましょう！
はい！
うわぁ！！
俺、上手いんすよ、俺上手いんすよ(2回目)
ヤバくない？！ヤバくない？！
上手いんすよ！！(3回目)
え…めっちゃ飛ぶやん……
うわっ
ヤバいヤバいヤバい×2
今見ました？
もうなんか、見えるかな
このレベルまで飛んでいきました
おっしゃー٩(ˊᗜˋ*)و
おぉ！すごい！すごい！すごい！すごい！
yeah！ハッハー！！ε٩(๑˃ꇴ˂๑)۶з
ォホホホホwwww
はいというわけで何回か遊んでみたんですけども
飛ぶね(確信)
めっちゃ飛びます…
今回なんですけども、ただこれで遊ぶのではなくぅ
まぁ世界記録が４０６m？
ですね
ここで１５０mなんですけど
あと多分１０mくらいしかないんで
この芝生公園多分１６０mだ
…じゃあな
(終わらないよぉ！)
どうするよぉ
とりあえず、１６０でやってみましょ
世界記録が出来る場所すらないという
ま！でもとりあえず、でもさ！
よく考えてみ？
フリスビーで、１６０m飛ぶこと事態脅威だよ？
とりあえず４００m……
まぁ、今回まぁプレテストみたいなもんだね
場所が無いんでとりあえず！
今できる最大限の１６０mを目指して
世界一飛ぶフリスビー、投げてみたいと思います！
僕が今できる最大限の力を示そうと思います
ではいきます…
もう一発でキメるから！
⁽⁽(ી₍₍⁽⁽(ી( ˆoˆ )ʃ)₎₎⁾⁾ʃ)₎₎
イマイチどこにあるかわからん。
どうだった？どうだった？
カメラで追えないっていう…
うぅえ？！
見辛いんすよ、上行っちゃうと
なるべく次、下で攻めるよ
了解です！
いきます！
4発目いきまーす！
なんか結構飛びはするんですけど、
風かな？なんかこう浮くんすよね
１００mは多分いってると思うんですけども
１６０はなかなか…いかないです
いきます！
走り方wwwwwwwww
どうだった！？
もう無理です(即答)
まだ早いよ。ここで諦めて良いのかよ？！
もっと上の目標があるんだろ！
そうだろ！？
ソ……ソーデスネ！
まだ諦めるのは早い！
ソーデスネ！！！！
やるぞ
やりましょう
(ガ…ガンバレ…！)
そして、最後のフリスビー
僕は、全力を尽くして投げたが
最後のフリスビーは
空を飛ばず、地面を走りめぐり
彼は、
持ち主の元に
帰ったのであった
あ、すいません！
＿人人 人人＿
＞  走り方  ＜
￣Y^Y^Y^Y￣
どうだった？
え、1回超えましたよ？
え、まじ？
１５０はいってるね
いってます！